in the end has been from start to finish
with Dolores has been in your life now
for how long
I guess it began the conversation began
back in 2017
yeah we were rehearsing for a tour that
we were about to do and that was for an
album at the time which was like an
acoustic album and of our old songs
um and the conversation began which it
might be nice to kind of write a new
hour-long new fresh material we hadn't
done that since 2017 yeah that tour came
to an end in May of that year so really
they're kind of the writing process
began in June and so it's kind of since
June of that year did the line share
from kind of June to December was
written for this album and just over a
year now since Dolores passed it took
ten months for the coroner's
investigation to know exactly what
happened or their interpretation of what
happened were you guys working on this
during that and was how difficult was
that process when you guys didn't even
have as friends and bandmates answers
well the doors have been in a very good
place before she passed away right but
we knew it was an accident it wasn't you
know I think there's no speculation I
know yeah we kind of had a feeling that
it was an accident
yeah us you know unfortunate tragic
thing to happen we kind of ignored all
that stuff that was going on in the
press and on Twitter or whatever so we
just got in the studio and kind of said
okay you know we have a job to do here
and we have to do justice to the songs
that the lawyer says has put her heart
and soul into you know he wants to kind
of do the best we could to try and what
are I suppose grief into best but also
passion you know because it's not a
morbid item um people might be surprised
by that that there's plenty of offbeat
songs and a bit and that shows that she
was in a good place you know is it more
was it more difficult yet recorded these
were demos that she had recorded and you
guys could have done whatever you want
with her tracks but did you go to her
family did you go to people and ask
I don't know permission or your family
we'd be very close with them even to
this day
and her brother is actually kind of
involved in the management sighted about
it anyway
so once we heard the songs really that's
how strong they were and particularly at
the vocals were you know they were so
good that we could easily even know they
were demos you could easily transfer
them across you know for us we were very
keen to finish the work that we'd begun
then and we did have that conversation
with the family they were kind of
relieved that we were going to do it
because they're I guess like many people
thought that's the end of that yeah we'd
never finish it so I mean it just
everything kind of just fell into place
we spoke to the family we had the songs
we spoke to our longtime producer who
loved what he heard as well and it was
actually his suggestion that we go in so
soon and kind of channel that kind of
whatever it was as feelings we had into
this album was there anything that she
wrote and said on the album that hit you
differently after she passed there's a
few songs yeah lost and Indians the
second song in the very last song yeah I
did two that really resonate with all
three of us as being just the most
emotional to try and capture because our
vocal is well in lastik kind of it
starts off really delicately and builds
into this massive crescendo and then in
the end it's just a really kind of
wistful sweet song that kind of speaks
about the grass being greener on the
other side you know and that was the
very last song we recorded together as
the grand boys you know we need to kind
of knew that that was at the end is
right when you are in such a devastating
place emotionally was it difficult to do
the up-tempo tracks to sort of get
yourself in that crash share to be out
was it yeah yeah yeah we started the
first first day was that all over now
which was the single um and it was kind
of a deliberate like that is a very
upbeat sarong basically and it was a
let's do that because it was it was well
developed for starters but it also to
start and I kind of wanted a more
downbeat one's might have set the wrong
tone and like that you know you have the
first few hours where you are a bit kind
of what what are we doing here but you
get so engrossed in what you're doing
and you have to
focus you know because you're not doing
any justice to songs to Dolores to de
band by kind of not focusing on what you
should be doing so you just took each
song and its own merit and tested it on
that day over the years I'm sure you
guys have had conversations about mental
health and bipolar and was Dolores the
type of individual that wrote better in
those darker times because that's the
sort of problematic aspect of being an
artist and suffering from something is
that you want to help yeah that's where
the art happens for a lot of people yeah
exactly like even the writing of this
album I couldn't keep up with her to
deliver music you know she she had been
through an awful lot and she was very
open about yeah everything in her life
and she kind of kept saying look I'm in
a really good place for writing right
now I've been so much to say like over
the past three years have been through
the wars in many ways and now that's
behind me so you were kind of working on
that and she always used to say over the
years like being in those places for her
creativity was perfect
yeah um she said like when she was in a
good mood she wanted to go for walks and
do the things that we all want to do and
then sitting-room kind of you know
letting it all out wasn't really at the
high in our list at that time so um so
definitely she would be she would be in
a place where she knew she could write
at that point and then she knew when she
couldn't so there was no time really
wasted right yeah her voice is just it's
unmistakable and when you first heard it
did you know that this was something
special yeah I mean the first day she
came in through her room she was spoken
to a guitar amp so it was kind of modish
shouldn't distort it you could sit here
and she could sing but about a month
later we went into the studio and did a
demo just for ourselves and then linger
was one of the first tracks we did and
she did that soprano back involve the
thing we were all looking a check on oh
my gosh you know you never really
realized she could do this you know the
you know a whole different thing it was
absolutely incredible for such a small
person to have this massive
operatic voice armless and I've always
been interested because Dolores is one
of those singers where you could tell
where she was from even when she's
saying and that is not often the case
with people with with any sort of accent
was it was there anybody along the road
that said hey maybe pronounce these
words a little bit more universally than
you are and did she fight back on that
at all because this album is full of
those things ya know no one ever said it
sorry of you mentors Tara what to do
very quickly so um and she you know she
was very proud of where she was sure and
she didn't really see the point of that
yeah you know to kind of get this kind
of mid-atlantic accent or something and
I think the more probably than anything
the more people kind of would say oh
your voice is amazing I love the way you
say this that it's probably embraced it
all the more than keep that with this
album the the process for recording was
different that the release is different
but there's also no tour happening which
is the first time that this has happened
so what happens so what happens now what
do you guys do now that you've given
this to the fans into the world what is
what are you guys doing but I think you
know we've been through a lot the last
year of yeah from that from that day in
January and then we were in recording
and we've been doing basically working
on this album for almost a year now yeah
we've been doing promo for a few months
as well and we're kind of getting to the
point I think we all want to take a
break from it especially this summer's
coming I was thinking you know we walk
away from it and there'll always be
little pieces to do with the band and I
guess you know we've been at it so long
you still want to be involved in music
somewhere somehow but we just haven't
really had enough time to kind of really
concentrate or think about anything
outside of this like the reactions the
album for the people that have heard it
has been amazing so far and we're
delighted that we even have the album to
give to people so I think it's the case
of kind of getting it out there and then
see what happens over the next few
months but definitely some time away
from the three of us is what we need and
although it is a it is very much a
celebration doing promo for this so you
guys are having to revisit the day you
heard that she died you have to revisit
all of all of this stuff are you guys
having conversations between the two of
you about how to handle that and how to
sort of relive that day no actually to
be honest you know during the day you
answer the questions you be as honest as
you can and then at night I find it kind
of filters down a bit more and you feel
a bit sad at night you know you know are
there still moments at disbelief yeah
yeah yeah penny back there it just it
seems all very grown-up stuff yeah you
know kind of stuff that you think you
deal with when you're older again so
we're not kids but it just it is and
even times you could be walking down the
street and someone from the back has the
same walk as her you know things like
that you still think you're kind of a
double-take it's very hard that a day
goes by you know you wouldn't really get
a day where you don't think of her at
some point yeah and knowing her as well
as you did in hell just sort of her ways
and yeah yeah what would she think of
the record yes I think she'd be very
proud I mean when we finished record and
we gave copies to her family yeah and
her mom couldn't listen to where she
said she had kind of not ready yet for
her brothers and sisters listened and
they kind of gave us a thumbs up and
said she'd be very proud of this it
sounds like a real classic cranberries
yeah record so it's nice to hear that